après trois heures de délibération le
verdict de la cour d'assises de l'yonne
est tombé le jury a condamné le couple
de sexagénaires pour le viol de leur
fille et belle fille alors mineure au
moment des faits neuf ans de prison pour
lui
cinq ans dont deux avec sursis et mise à
l'épreuve pour elle des peines qui vont
plus loin que les réquisitions du
parquet pour katia violée par son père
justice a été rendue
quelque part c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on attendait on pensait pas qu'ils
allaient prendre autant mais jusqu'à
mérite et j'ai vu enfin on fournier
reconnu enfin justice rendue durant ces
trois jours la cour d'assises à examiner
ces faits de viol incestueux de 1992 à
l'homme et sa concubine ont abusé de
leur fille et belles filles à leurs
mineurs à vos d'heure dans le sénonais
trois jours de procès pendant lesquelles
le couple de sexagénaires a continué à
nier les faits et n'a surtout exprimé
aucun regret leurs avocats n'ont pas
souhaité faire de déclarations à
l'énoncé du verdict mais ils regrettent
que leur client est campé sur leurs
positions
ils ont dix jours pour faire appel les
deux condamnés ont été écroués et ont
passé la nuit en prison